it's probably not going to come as a big
shock to you that Comcast is spreading
anti Net Neutrality propaganda you might
recall that in 2015 the FCC issued the
open Internet order and that established
some basic net neutrality principles
under the law the order classified
Internet service providers as common
carriers under title 2 of the 1934
Communications Act giving the FCC more
authority to regulate them and using
title 2 like this is how you enforce net
neutrality otherwise the net neutrality
laws are basically useless if you don't
have this designation for Internet
service providers Comcast is creating
anti net neutrality propaganda to try to
fight back against that really important
classification of Internet service
providers as common carriers here's a
tweet from Comcast and you'll see how
cleverly disguised this propaganda is
they said quote there's widespread
consensus on net neutrality protections
and we support them read more and then
they provide a link so it sounds like oh
wow Comcast is in favor of net
neutrality when you click on the link it
takes you to this page which we're
showing our TV audience on Comcast
website and it's a message from Comcast
president Dave Watson which says in part
quote whether you are a Comcast customer
or just an interested observer you may
be hearing a lot about net neutrality
and openness on the Internet let me be
clear
Comcast supports strong legally
enforceable net neutrality protections
that ensure a free and open Internet for
all of our customers our customers
expect that we will protect their right
to enjoy an open Internet and that is
exactly what we do every day sounds
pretty good right seems like they must
really believe in net neutrality at
Comcast the letter goes on to say this
is how we run our internet business our
network and business practices are in
complete alignment with these
protections that will remain true even
if the FCC reverses public utility
regulation of our broadband network
basically saying even if net neutrality
goes away we will still do the right
thing and the letter goes on to say as
our chairman and CEO Brian Roberts made
today as well as my colleague David
colleague David Cohen explained in a
blog post today title 2 and net
neutrality are two different things
you can absolutely be for net neutrality
which we are but against using outdated
utility regulation to do it there are
better ways to guarantee net neutrality
than classifying all broadband
businesses under title 2 public utility
regulations of course he doesn't mention
what those better ways are and that's
because again title 2 is how you enforce
and guarantee net neutrality and that
doesn't explain they don't explain why
they're against title 2 and that's
because it allows the FCC to regulate
them and enforce net neutrality title 2
is net neutrality and Comcast says were
for net neutrality but we're against
title 2 they're basically saying net
neutrality is a great thing and were for
it but that statement is meaningless
because if you don't have the FCC
classifying Internet service providers
as common carriers essentially there's
no power to enforce net neutrality
here's another tweet from Comcast about
this we believe in an open Internet and
give our customers the net neutrality
protections they expect again
meaningless statement but they're
advocating for the opposite they're
saying here's what we are in favor of oh
but by the way we want to get rid of
this title to common carrier designation
this is desperate I mean they're
tweeting at random people on the
Internet in response to all of the smoke
blowing someone asked Comcast on Twitter
in response to this stuff quote then why
did you spend all that money lobbying to
get a change and Comcast replied title 2
does not equal net neutrality best way
to ensure net neutrality is
congressional action Comcast knows that
that's not going to happen under the
current Congress Congress just gave
Comcast the right to sell your internet
history the idea that you can get rid of
the title 2 stuff and Congress will do
the right thing is so bogus especially
when we know about new FCC Chairman Ajit
PI who spent his career as a lawyer for
telecom company
pretty clever by Comcast right it just
people have litigated this they want to
keep net neutrality the law of the land
public polling suggests this and it's a
very concerning time when a G pi is the
head of the FCC yes and we have a
president who has no idea what he's
talking about when it comes to this
matter and this is a good opportunity to
mention an interview that you may not
know about Pat it's a couple year old
interview I once interviewed someone
named Crystal High who showed up and the
pitch was she is going to talk about
Internet freedom and she was pitched as
sort of like an Internet freedom guest
and we did some background research and
figured out she was a paid shill for the
anti net neutrality ISP establishment
and I called her out on it during the
interview she was completely flummoxed
it's one of the best interviews I mean
she gets caught red-handed and she ends
up admitting that yes she's financially
compensated for going out and repeating
these talking points Krystal hi KR k RI
no i think it's k ry st al so that was
probably a few years ago when net
neutrality was last being debated i am
delivering that back as a classic
interview i think i think it was from
2015 yeah very very good interview i
encourage you to check it out propaganda
from comcast probably not surprising
today's episode of the david pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial com /t DPS